all right so jim and berlin you are the
father
and berlin is the sister of chris
this is my daughter who you uh who i
interviewed recently he's a
schizophrenic young man who
is using crystal meth and lives here on
skid row somewhere correct we haven't
been able to find him yet but
but he's around i saw him a couple days
ago um
tell me the background with with chris
he uh
he's he's he began with uh marijuana so
yeah i think he was
probably 14-ish and
was hanging out with some friends and
started smoking pot and
[Music]
made it through high school i think he
also started drinking a lot
probably his senior year you know you
were there too and
um i'd say senior year and he
we drug him through high school he
graduated and
got a couple jobs started moving on to
the alcohol and the pot and then a few
stronger things i think
acid or lsd whatever whichever he could
find
and then uh but he also we also noticed
that he had the
kind of this um not really schizophrenic
but more like
paranoid behavior a lot uh which we
realized later was
schizophrenia and i think when he was
18 was it 18 19ish
he got diagnosed with adhd
actually was 17 it was his senior year
got diagnosed with adhd
and then also bipolar
slight bipolar so then it was at that
point that we realized that
chris was a special person and we were
going to be dealing with it for a while
and i think the
the reality when i moved to huntington
beach
from utah is he grew up in salt lake and
berlin was going to come with me but she
decided to stay in salt lake
i took a job down here and then two
years later chris moved down with me
because he got kicked out of his mom's
house and he was living on the streets
in salt lake
called me and asked if i could help him
so i said yeah come on down we'll take
care of you
so he came down and i pretty much
enabled him for a couple years
and when he turned 21
he had a pretty good job at toyota was
doing pretty well
and decided that he didn't want to work
anymore he started just smoking a lot of
pot and drinking
because he could buy both legally in
california
and kind of went downhill from there he
had to go into a rehab program and he's
been in and out of those for a few years
and chris just went the wayward side i
mean he ended up
getting into the meth and having a hard
time with it gotten a fight in san diego
with somebody and ended up
getting charged and going to jail and i
think that forced his rehab for a while
but it didn't didn't make him change
it's like we said mental illness is one
thing and
he definitely has it and the
schizophrenia he could
like he said in his interview he has
drugs that he could take
to help with his mental illness but he
doesn't take him he prefers the
easier way out the way that the drugs
make him feel better and make him
escape from reality in life
and there's a history of of men like
schizophrenia or something like that in
your family
or in his family a little bit on my
mom's side yeah
um i believe my great-grandpa was a
schizophrenic as well
yeah he had some issues in and out of
hospitals and same thing
was a fighter yeah gotten a lot of
fights
and berlin you you've you've seen him
deteriorate in the last
few years um yeah
he i've definitely noticed it i
went out to california a couple times
when he had moved out there
initially with my dad and he seemed like
he was doing well but
every once in a while he would have
these episodes
where he'd freak out and it was
kind of it was pretty traumatizing it
was
definitely scary scary yeah and
um i think i was i was still kind of
i was still pretty young so i didn't
really understand fully what was going
on and how his brain was
functioning completely different than
ours i
um i kind of looked i feel like i kind
of looked at it the wrong way and i
always like
thought it was his fault and he was just
acting out i didn't really
realize that it was a mental illness and
then he doesn't really
have control of it unless he
stays on his medication which of course
he didn't want to do
but um yeah we came out i came out
in february with him to visit
chris when he was still in one of his
rehab facilities
and he looked like a completely
different person
i didn't recognize him but it i think it
was the fact that he had been
off of drugs for so long because he was
in jail
and had actually like gained weight
but he also i think he was so freshly
out of jail that he didn't really know
how to
respond and
i remember leaving that trip just like i
don't even know
who he is anymore but
um that was kind of an eye-opener yeah
and then he like it's like he come he
comes in and out like he'll
he'll go through phases where he talks
to me and like he seems so like happy
you know like
talk about like old memories that
me and him shared when we were kids and
like
will like laugh and giggle with me on
the phone and then there's other days
where i
talk to him and he tells me he's not
doing good and
doesn't really want to talk but
from the interview that i saw with you
that's like the way that he looked there
he like
looks like he's lost some weight which
is what i remember him in high school
and the long
shaggy hair and he actually looked
comparatively
well compared to when i saw him in
february
yeah surprisingly he did look a little
better
but he was definitely mentally he wasn't
better
yeah and i think physically he hadn't
you know obviously
been going through stuff and he hadn't
eaten as much so he was definitely
skinnier
it's got to be tremendously frustrating
as
his dad and sister to to see this and
and yeah you want to do anything for him
right yeah but
what can you do yeah i i definitely i
find myself
beating myself up a lot about it because
there's nothing that i
well i mean like all i can do is be
there to help him when he needs help
but i can't make him change and that's
like
you can't make him be a different person
and that's one of the hardest pills to
swallow with it i think
and just being able to accept that he is
the way that he is and
it's also plays into a factor that he's
an adult and he
is allowed to make his own choices even
if they're not he's of age and he can do
what he wants and you can't
force him to do anything yeah no and any
any monetary help we give him just
enables him
uh so it's all got to be love and you
know mental type support
and hoping that like he said in that
interview that he's hit rock bottom and
hoping that that's really true and he
wants to accept
actual help and love and make sure you
guys could do anything
yeah absolutely i mean i i see it and
when i first started doing this
i would see people that needed needed
rehab
and i was very naive at the time and i
would say oh well here
let me let me help you with rehab let me
give you some money to go to rehab
he's been in three so but i've i learned
very quickly that that doesn't work they
they don't use the money for rehab and
then i started like maybe
paying for rehab i would pay the rehab
and and that didn't work either
you know because the people people might
say they want rehab but
they don't have the ability to follow
through and he said that this last time
i said we're not paying for it we're not
going to do it you're going to have to
figure out something on your own
state rehab state help
county help whatever it is you're going
to have to figure it out and i gave him
some numbers and i also helped call a
few places and that's what got him into
the one in san diego
and i kept saying you've just got to
stick to the program and he would for a
while but then he'd start sneaking out
at night and doing his thing and finding
he knew where to go
and that was part of i need to get him
out of this environment so he doesn't
know
nowhere to go to get the drugs and
doesn't know where to go to
figure out how to get his next high and
getting him out of that environment is
going to be the only thing that really
will save him get him out of this
environment and skid row
is the only thing that's really going to
save him too yeah i mean going to rehab
and stay in rehab are very different
things
yes i've learned and then you know here
on skid row if he's if he's down here
he's
he's walking past 20 opportunities to go
to rehab every day right
he walks around ignoring him and looking
for his next score exactly yeah
and our biggest worry is is the next
telephone
call from the la area is somebody saying
hey we need you to pick up your son
he's in you know he's in the hospital or
come identify his body you know which is
the worst thing a parent ever wants to
hear i don't want to outlive my kids
you know i definitely want them to grow
old and be happy
sure of course i don't want to ever get
that call and so that's why
i'm always trying to find him trying to
figure out a way to help him and
and be the guy that at least said i did
everything i could
and didn't turn my back on yeah so so
you're down here hopefully
looking looking we're hoping to find him
but it doesn't look like we're going to
this trip
yeah it's a birthday tomorrow oh yeah
tomorrow he turns 25.
is that right yeah so i'll let you know
and i saw him on monday and i'll i'll
let you know if i can find him again i
asked him to come by this week
every day but he hasn't so yeah and this
year was supposed to be the year we were
actually going to
spend and have dinner and cake and hang
out on a birthday
we haven't done that for i think four
years
so because he's either been in rehab or
jail
so this was going to be the year
so maybe next year it's such a
heartbreaking story
like like so many yeah people down here
so many parents i know are in the same
boat
and you know i know in the back of their
mind they're not giving up even though
sometimes they say they have and
and it has to be tough love and you have
to continue with your life
i mean you can you can let this eat you
up and it could become your life
but you're not going to help them
especially if you don't find them
and if you try and over protect them
and try and do everything for them then
it's pretty much just going to be the
enabling that
they want they're going to get what they
want out of you and work it
and being a drug addict i know they're
very manipulative and they'll do what
they have to
to get what they need it's it's insane
how
how manipulative they can be because
i've i've been
fooled and tricked so many times by
people who said oh yeah
i just want help and i'm like the help
turns into enabling
like that mark you have 20 bucks i need
some for parking
yeah of course yeah sure yeah it's just
generosity it's like no it's just i'm i
tend to be a
sucker or a kind person whatever you
want to call it kind people
are the worst yeah no i i i i'm like
sure
okay you seem sincere and and it very
easily
yeah turns into what they really want
which is another fix
that's the bottom line and well you know
it's one of those things where you look
at it and say hey
i want you to spend this energy that you
are using to get your next fix
on doing something productive for you
think of how much money you could
actually be making if all this time
you were spending trying to get your
next fix you were spending on something
that was making you some money or
something that was doing you some good
you would be so much more better of a
person
and if everybody could do that that was
out there trying to get that fixed but i
know
it goes back to the mental illness thing
too if they have that mental illness
they're not taking their meds
then they're trying to figure out how to
get rid of those voices
of all the thousands of people i've
interviewed i've only seen just just
less than a handful that have really
made the series change
and it's taken real it's really just
been their own
the the the addict's decision on their
own they get
tired of being tired and they and they
follow through with
the decision somehow miraculously and
they we're gonna do it but they
it's still a struggle well and and if
this helps
anybody you know any parent out there
it's like just
know that they're there and that you can
help them and
that the best way to help them is to be
tough but also
just ask them what they want ask them
what they really need and get them back
into a program
get them to take their meds ninety
percent of the kids out there
are having medical or mental problems
and they can be helped
with medicine and or some kind of work
program or something to keep their mind
off of
what's really bothering them i think
that's you know
the easiest simplest form to put it in
and if this can help one person out
there then i'm grateful and hopefully it
helps
bring chris back to us yeah
jim in berlin thank you so much for for
coming in and
thank you sharing your thoughts on this
it's it's it's a common problem i think
and very common yeah and i wish i wish
you guys the best of luck and i hope
chris
can somehow figure out a way to get help
and
get happy birthday chris if you see this
happy birthday
all right you guys thank you very much
thanks mark good luck thank you